>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD,
DUELING SPEECHES.
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
AND FORMER VICE PRESIDENT MIKE
PENCE BOTH SPOKE IN WASHINGTON,
D.C. TODAY.
PENCE TOLD SUPPORTERS NOT TO,
QUOTE, FOCUS ON THE PAST.
WHILE TRUMP WAS FOCUSED ON THE
PAST.
SLAMMING THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE AND CALLING THEM,
QUOTE, THUGS.
CNN'S KRISTEN HOLMES BREAKS DOWN
THE CONFLICTING MESSAGES FROM
THE TWO FORMER LEADERS OF THE
GOP.
>> FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
BACK IN WASHINGTON.
>> WE HAD MADE AMERICA GREAT
AGAIN.
WE HAD MADE IT GREAT AGAIN.
>> DELIVERING REMARKS FOCUSED ON
LAW ENFORCEMENT, AS HIS ACTIONS
ON JANUARY 6th REMAIN UNDER
SCRUTINY A YEAR AND A HALF
REMOVED FROM THE VIOLENT ATTACK
ON THE CAPITOL.
>> THERE IS NO LONGER RESPECT
FOR THE LAW, AND THERE CERTAINLY
IS NO ORDER.
OUR COUNTRY IS NOW A CESSPOOL OF
CRIME.
>> SPEAKING AT A CONSERVATIVE
THINK TANK FOUNDED BY FORMER
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS,
TRUMP LARGELY STAYED AWAY FROM
HIS GRIEVANCES AROUND THE 2020
ELECTION.
>> I RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
I WON, AND A WON A SECOND TIME,
DID MUCH BETTER THE SECOND TIME.
>> BLOCKS AWAY, FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE OUTLINING
HIS OWN VISION FOR THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
AT A GATHERING OF YOUNG
CONSERVATIVES.
>> NOW, SOME PEOPLE MAY CHOOSE
TO FOCUS ON THE PAST.
BUT ELECTIONS ARE ABOUT THE
FUTURE.
AND I BELIEVE CONSERVATIVES MUST
FOCUS ON THE FUTURE TO WIN BACK
AMERICA.
>> DO YOU THINK --
>> AFTER HIS REMARKS, THE FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT ASKED BY AN
AUDIENCE MEMBER ABOUT THE DIVIDE
BETWEEN HE AND TRUMP.
>> I WILL TELL YOU THAT I
COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD OF THE
RECORD OF THE TRUMP/PENCE
ADMINISTRATION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT OUR MOVEMENT
IS THAT DIVIDED.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT
AND I DIFFER ON ISSUES.
BUT WE MAY DIFFER ON FOCUS.
I TRULY DO BELIEVE THAT
ELECTIONS ARE ABOUT THE FUTURE.
AND THAT IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL AT A TIME WHEN SO MANY
AMERICANS ARE HURTING.
>> THE DUELING SPEECHES BETWEEN
PENCE AND TRUMP JUST THE LATEST
SALVO IN A PUBLIC SPLIT BETWEEN
THE TWO GOP LEADERS.
AS BOTH MEN LAY THE GROUNDWORK
FOR PRESIDENTIAL RUNS IN 2024.
>> I'M HERE BEFORE YOU TO BEGIN
TO TALK ABOUT WHAT WE MUST DO TO
ACHIEVE THAT FUTURE.
WHEN WE WIN A TRIUMPHANT VICTORY
IN 2022 AND WHEN A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT TAKES BACK THE WHITE
HOUSE IN 2024, WHICH I STRONGLY
BELIEVE WILL HAPPEN.
>> THEY ARE ENGAGED IN A PROXY
BATTLE IN THE ARIZONA PRIMARY
NEXT MONTH AFTER SQUARING OFF IN
THE GEORGIA REPUBLICAN PRIMARY
FOR GOVERNOR THIS SPRING.
>> I THINK THE TIME HAS COME FOR
US TO OFFER A BOLD, POSITIVE
AGENDA TO BRING AMERICA BACK.
AND I'LL CONTINUE TO CARRY THAT
MESSAGE ALL ACROSS THIS NATION.
>> FOR HIS PART, PENCE HAS BEEN
DELIBERATE IN SEEKING OUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO DISTANCE
HIMSELF FROM TRUMP.
AS THE HOUSE SELECT COMMITTEE
INVESTIGATING THE EVENTS OF
JANUARY 6th SHEDS MORE LIGHT ON
TRUMP'S FAILURE TO ACT THAT DAY.
AND THE DANGER PENCE FACED AMID
THE ATTACK.
AND WHILE PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
NOTABLY SPEND A LOT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT,
PRAISING LAW ENFORCEMENT, HE
DIDN'T MENTION ANY OF THE
OFFICERS WHO WERE SERVING ON
CAPITOL HILL THAT DAY, INCLUDING
THOSE WHO WERE INJURED OR
KILLED.
HOWEVER, HE DID TAKE TIME TO
ATTACK THE COMMITTEE, AS YOU
NOTED, CALLING THEM POLITICAL
HACKS AND THUGS, AND SAYING THAT
THEY WANTED TO DAMAGE HIM SO
THAT HE COULDN'T WORK FOR HIS
SUPPORTERS, JAKE.
>> KRISTEN HOLMES, THANKS SO
MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS ALL OF THE EVENTS
OF TODAY, AND PAUL, I DO WANT TO
START WITH LESTER HOLT'S
INTERVIEW WITH ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND.
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT GARLAND
TOLD HOLT WHEN ASKED IF HE IS
WORRIED AN INDICTMENT OF DONALD
TRUMP COULD RIP THE COUNTRY
APART.
>> WE INTEND TO HOLD EVERYONE,
ANYONE, WHO IS CRIMINALLY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE EVENTS
SURROUNDING JANUARY 6th, FOR ANY
ATTEMPT TO INTERFERE WITH THE
LAWFUL TRANSFER OF POWER FROM
ONE ADMINISTRATION TO ANOTHER,
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> SO IF DONALD TRUMP WERE TO
BECOME A CANDIDATE FOR PRESIDENT
AGAIN, THAT WOULD NOT CHANGE
YOUR SCHEDULE OR HOW YOU MOVE
FORWARD OR DON'T MOVE FORWARD?
>> I'LL SAY AGAIN THAT WE WILL
HOLD ACCOUNTABLE ANYONE WHO IS
CRIMINALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
ATTEMPTING TO INTERFERE WITH THE
TRANSFER, LEGITIMATE, LAWFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER FROM ONE
ADMINISTRATION TO THE NEXT.
>> THE KEY WORD IN THERE IS
CRIMINALLY RESPONSIBLE.
BECAUSE IT'S OBVIOUS THAT DONALD
TRUMP WAS MORALLY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE EVENTS SURROUNDING
JANUARY 6th AND THE ATTEMPT TO
INTERFERE WITH THE LAWFUL
TRANSFER OF POWER, BUT
CRIMINALLY.
DO YOU THINK ATTORNEY GENERAL
GARLAND AT THE END OF THE DAY
WILL FIND DONALD TRUMP
CRIMINALLY RESPONSIBLE OR BE
WILLING TO?
>> THIS IS WHY HE'S A LAWYER'S
LAWYER.
THAT ANSWER, HE SAID EVERYTHING
AND NOTHING.
RIGHT?
ACTUALLY, AND I'M SURE LESTER IS
A VERY GOOD JOURNALIST, AND I
THINK HE PROBABLY ASKED THIS, I
HOPE HE DID.
HAVEN'T SEEN THE INTERVIEW.
WHAT ABOUT THE MUELLER REPORT?
I UNDERSTAND 1/6 TAKES A WHILE,
A LONG INVESTIGATION, THEY'RE
WORKING THROUGH IT.
THERE'S A GRAND JURY.
OKAY, I RESPECT THAT.
THE MUELLER REPORT CAME OUT
THREE YEARS AND THREE MONTHS
AGO.
AND MR. MUELLER NOTES TEN
DIFFERENT INSTANCES WHERE DONALD
TRUMP MAY HAVE COMMITTED
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
THERE'S NO NEW INFORMATION, NO
NEW INVESTIGATION.
HE'S BEEN SITTING ON THAT SINCE
THE DAY HE WALKED IN THE DOOR.
>> AND MUELLER TESTIFIED THAT
DONALD TRUMP ONCE HE LEFT OFFICE
COULD BE FOUND --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
DONALD TRUMP IS NO LONGER
PRESIDENT, IT'S BEEN IN ALL THE
PAPERS.
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND KNOWS
THAT.
I WANT TO KNOW, IF TRUMP IS
INNOCENT, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SHOULD SAY THAT.
THEY SHOULD.
IF HE'S NOT, THEY SHOULD
PROSECUTOR HIM.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION
TO SOMETHING WE JUST GOT, THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE JUST
RELEASED TESTIMONY FROM CHRIS
MILLER WHERE THEY ASK HID ABOUT
THEN CHIEF OF STAFF MARK MEADOWS
STATEMENTS THAT TRUMP HAD
ORDERED 10,000 TROOPS TO BE
READY BEFORE JANUARY 6th.
TAKE A LISTEN TO PART OF
SECRETARY MILLER'S ANSWER.
>> TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR, THERE
WAS NO DIRECT ORDER FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO PUT 10,000
TROOPS TO BE ON THE READY FOR
JANUARY 6th, CORRECT?
>> NO.
YEAH, THAT'S CORRECT.
THERE WAS NO ORDER FROM THE
PRESIDENT.
>> NO ORDER FROM THE PRESIDENT.
WE SHOULD NOTE, MARK MEADOWS
SAID SOMETHING DIFFERENT, BUT HE
SAID IT NOT UNDER OATH ON FOX.
SECRETARY MILLER WAS UNDER OATH.
>> I THINK IT'S FURTHER EVIDENCE
TO THE FACT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
CHOSE TO DO NOTHING ON JANUARY
6th.
HE IN FACT, THAT'S WHAT THIS
WHOLE HEARING IS ABOUT.
THESE HEARINGS ARE ABOUT, WHAT
LEVEL OF CULPABILITY HE HAS HAD
AND WHAT WE LEARNED IS THIS IS A
CONSPIRACY.
THIS WASN'T SOME ONE-OFF EVENT
OR RANDOM EVENT.
THERE MAY BE PEOPLE WHO WERE
SWEPT UP IN IT ON THAT DAY, BUT
THIS IS FURTHER PROOF THAT HE
DID NOTHING TO PREVENT THIS OR
STOP THIS.
THERE WAS A COMPLETE DERELICTION
OF DUTY AND THAT'S THE HARSH
REALITY.
>> I HAVE HEARD DEMOCRATS
CRITICIZE WHAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAID.
BIDEN IS ACCUSING TRUMP NOW OF
NOT HAVING ENOUGH COURAGE TO
STOP WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY
6th.
BUT I HAVE HEARD DEMOCRATS SAY,
NOT HAVE ENOUGH COURAGE?
IT WAS THE PLAN.
IT WAS THE PLAN TO GET THE MOB
TO GO THERE.
>> YEAH, I THINK THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE HAVE LEARNED FROM THE
JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
WE SORT OF KNEW IT BEFORE THEY
LAID IT ALL OUT FOR US IN
DETAIL, BUT NOW THAT WE KNOW
THAT HE WAS AWARE THAT THAT MOB
WAS ARMED AND THAT HE SAID TO
PEOPLE AROUND HIM THAT THEY WERE
NOT THERE TO HURT HIM, RIGHT, HE
KNEW HE WOULD BE SAFE IN THIS
ARMED MOB.
HE SENDS THEM DOWN TO THE
CAPITOL ANYWAY, AND THEN THE
LAST HEARING DEMONSTRATED HE SAT
AND WATCHED TELEVISION UNTIL IT
WAS CLEAR OTHER PEOPLE HAD TAKEN
CARE OF THE MESS, THE FBI WAS ON
THE CASE, AND HIS PEOPLE WERE
BEING CLEARED OUT OF THE
CAPITOL.
SO YEAH, IT'S NOT -- THE WAY
THAT THE PRESIDENT FRAMED IT
WASN'T QUITE RIGHT.
>> WE HEARD, NIA, WE HEARD
KRISTEN HOLMES TALKING ABOUT
THESE DUELING SPEECHES IN D.C.
TODAY.
WHERE BASICALLY VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE SAYS I AGREE WITH TRUMP ON
EVERYTHING EXCEPT THE FACT THAT
HE WANTS TO KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THE ELECTION, AND HIS BOOK,
PENCE HAS A BOOK COMING OUT THIS
FALL IN WHICH THE PUBLISHER'S
NOTES DESCRIBE THE BREAK THAT
THEY HAD AND PENCE STANDING UP
FOR THE CONSTITUTION.
AND YET, AND YET, A NEW CNN POLL
SHOWS REPUBLICANS WHEN ASKED WHO
TO PUT UP FOR PRESIDENT IN 2020,
44% OF REPUBLICANS SAY TRUMP,
55% SAY SOMEONE ELSE.
>> TRUMP IS THE CLEAR FRONT
RUNNER FOR THE NOMINATION IN
2024 SHOULD HE SEEK IT.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS, IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF TIMING WHEN HE
ACTUALLY ANNOUNCES HE WANTS TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
WE SAW IN 2016, HE DIDN'T NEED
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE.
HE JUST NEEDED TO WIN BY A
LITTLE.
IN ANY OF THESE STATES BECAUSE
IT'S A WINNER TAKE ALL SYSTEM.
IF PEOPLE JOIN THE RACE AND RUN
AGAINST TRUMP, IT'S VERY LIKELY
THAT HE COULD WIN AGAIN.
IDEALOGICAL HEART AND SOUL OF
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS WITH
DONALD TRUMP.
NOTHING HAS SHAKEN THEIR, YOU
KNOW, THEIR FAITH IN HIM, THE
SENSE THAT HE REPRESENTS WHO
THEY ARE.
HE WOULD RUN ESSENTIALLY SAYING
LISTEN, IN 2020, YOU GOT YOUR
BIRTH RITE STOLEN.
YOUR COUNTRY WAS STOLEN FOR YOU,
AND I DONALD TRUMP AM HERE TO
REDEEM THAT AND RESTORE YOUR